I have the luxury of having a screen and
video anyways so I've got like an intro
video where I'd say like you know you're
gonna see I put a lot of work into this
show and you're not invited to steal it
so please don't yeah and that's I found
pretty effective really yeah he caught
somebody recording this has happened a
bunch of times most of the time by the
way when they're filming they just want
to be able to show their friends not
send it to anybody like look I was at a
Steve show yeah but Steve jumped off on
stage you don't know yeah he [ __ ]
grabbed that happened a bunch of times
you've jumped off stage you've jumped
off the stage while performing grab the
person's phone they follow me on then
these like delete it and then then show
me your delete box and then delete it
again and that happens how often does
that happen I mean it doesn't happen a
lot but I'm just protective yeah out of
it because then I'm looking around the
room and sometimes like I'm just taking
a picture I'm like I don't know that now
I'm thinking like what am I saying
because sometimes I'm saying well maybe
not offensive stuff but like stuff
that's like this shouldn't be out there
this is just for the live experience
there's another time years ago when we
were it was 2014 we were in New Zealand
and uh so this is and I didn't blow a
load the entire year of 2014. you're a
[ __ ] loser idiot he went 430
something days without blowing a loaded
sex addict rehab
so I'm I'm in this celibacy period I'm
flipping my lips no I didn't blow alone
for the whole time celibate and uh
during that period we were in New
Zealand and that's some chick was
filming
and I like berated or I went off
and uh there was like a a prince
journalist in the crowd who just wrote
this story about what a terrible [ __ ]
I was and I was like if I just let the
chick record like nobody would have seen
it but now this story story comes out
with like in a proper Outlet yeah it's
not right though it turned out to be a
hard honor yeah there is a point in time
because I'd be like backstage in the
green room and you just hear the mic
drop boom it'd be done it should be
somebody talking and it's just and I'd
like run out to see it he's just like
but you just shut the [ __ ] up and
they're just like having to cover you
know just a little conversation but like
he was so on edge from not blowing a
load oh and it just was happening wow
that ends like that the heckling and the
table talk and the video recording like
it all just like builds up it
accumulates and it gets to a point where
you're just like I can't take it anymore
you ever seen Nina Simone
yeah like a singer but she was like she
was like it's my show you better be
[ __ ] respect that was her vibe and
she's starting to play the piano there's
videos this and someone just like coffee
and she'll just stop him
[Music]
for sure
and then go back and people were scared
of her wow
I uh it's like Steve when you like air
footage and you show people and somebody
says something he'll stop and he'll be
like and then he'll rewind it to where
they started talking I play it again
dude how was your load on the 440 it was
it was underwhelming right it's not you
didn't save up you just stopped
producing yeah yeah it was underwhelming
it didn't even feel that great and it
wasn't like that huge was your load in
your hand or was it landed on my tummy
and I took a picture of it and sent it
to everybody
yeah I wonder like on on PornHub like if
it said like you know 432 day load like
that would crush you know right for sure
I would click on that you could have
sold that load
nft load yeah yeah it's called Stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and if you
go on Amazon and type in Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and Order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of Amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on Amazon and buy Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole yeah
dude